foreign
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show you know
um Pat will often communicate to me what
should or could be on the bonus show or
sometimes I will communicate it to him
and we'll kind of have you know we'll
we'll plan the bonus show it's not
award-winning for no reason right I mean
we are planning this thing and last
night Pat basically sends me the email
saying on the bonus show producer Pat
collapses at the finish line of a half
marathon heat stroke wakes up in an ice
bath was more or less what you told me
right
yep that's the summary of what happened
um so everyone wants to hear the full
version yeah let's talk through it so I
don't even know if you had mentioned you
were doing a half marathon on the show
had you mentioned that I hadn't
mentioned it on the show which is funny
because Runners seem to love to tell
everyone about the races that they're
running
um but I was able to hold back I didn't
tell anyone it probably would have come
up at some point but nope I didn't
mention it so you do a a half marathon
over Memorial Day weekend it's been
super hot or it was super hot over
Memorial Day weekend it was a 7 A.M
start I mean give us the rundown what
happened all right so I've had periods
of time in my life where I've been into
running and then out of running again
and for the past I'd say about six
months or so I've been into it you know
consistently training running a couple
times a week a few times a week and I
thought that it would be cool to run an
actual race because I had never done
that before aside from like high school
track I had never done one of these like
community the long runs or anything like
that and I saw this half marathon coming
up and I was like that's perfect I got
enough time to train for it that sounds
like the race for me and so you know I'm
going through the training and I'm
getting faster and I start to think
about what kind of pace I want to run
for the race and you know I'm doing all
like the standard things to prepare for
the race however one detail that becomes
relevant when you hear the whole story
is that most of the training that I was
doing uh was during temperatures of
about 50 to 60 degrees Fahrenheit you
know it's early Springtime late winter
in uh in New England
and so I really wasn't accustomed to
running in any hotter than that
especially for a long distance
um so then uh you know race day comes
around and I feel like I'm prepared for
it I have my goal time in mind and I
really do all the right things to get me
set up you know I'm hydrated I had
plenty of fluids the night before and
then uh you know I'm at the starting
line any anything you want to say before
I continue here no so I mean this was an
early morning start which I know you
said wasn't like the best thing for you
but did you have time to hydrate in the
morning as well like everything yeah a
little time in the morning and of course
there's Aid stations as you go along the
course yeah and I took advantage of that
too every single aid station I stopped
through I had a water I missed the first
one but everyone after that I got and I
also had a couple of gels which uh
Runners have to give you a little extra
glucose and some sodium so you don't
cramp and a little bit this is something
you eat it's like a like a like a gel
that you like a little gel Pace it's
pretty easy to eat so I had a couple of
those during the race it's recommended
for distance runs as well and like the
race itself was fun I was worried about
getting off to a uh too fast of a start
because I guess that's pretty common in
races because you have all that
adrenaline uh pushing through you and uh
no I was able to stay relaxed I kept the
pace that I wanted for the first like
eight or nine miles I was feeling good
it was it was really like soaked up in
the energy of the whole thing because
again I'd never done anything like this
before and it was pretty crazy to be
like running through the streets of a
major city with all these human beings
around you you feel like a pack of
animals or something like that but you
know the energy was great obviously
people cheering you on really had a
great time and felt totally fine for the
first seven eight miles or so yeah when
it started off what was the temperature
at the start because it started early it
was about 60 degrees okay so when you
started it felt like your training
sessions yeah totally fine and it was 7
A.M as you mentioned uh but you know
it's about a two hour race for me so by
the time the race was over it was more
like 80 degrees now did you go did you
feel fine through the first half of the
race yeah I felt totally fine um you
know I was able to stay on pace around
mile Eight Mile nine that's when it
started to hurt a lot more okay but I
expected that right because this is what
you train for you're supposed to be
feeling pretty good and capable of doing
the running for the first half or so and
then it's supposed to get challenging as
the race goes on you're supposed to get
more fatigued your legs are supposed to
get heavier you're supposed to get more
exhausted and so all this stuff was
happening but that was normal I
experienced that obviously in training
and you just you teach yourself to push
through it keep going focus on your
music just you know take it one mile at
a time right and so I was doing that uh
by Mile 10 or so I started thinking
about the end of the race because that's
at the time when you can like start
thinking about being done with this
thing yeah I started falling off the
pace unfortunately because my legs could
only carry me so fast so I was starting
to slow down but I was like all right I
can still get a good time you know just
gotta see this thing through
and and only in retrospect do I realize
that by like mile 11 12 I was starting
to get a little bit more Delirious I
knew that I was nearing the end and I
kind of had a sense of what the course
map was like and I knew I just had like
a few streets to go and then once you
get to the very end around mile 13 like
you know the last half mile or so
um you can see the finish line for a
long while and I was just so focused on
you know giving it my all finishing this
thing you know in training of course
you're thinking about what that moment's
going to be like when you can see the
Finish Line in the distance and you want
to give it 110 and so in this 80 degree
weather out there running 13 miles I'm
running you know as fast as I can to get
across the finish line so I can finally
be done with this thing
and I even do like a victory pose like
hands up in my air as I'm crossing the
finish line so that was one question you
did cross the finish line I did okay
okay yeah yeah my my time was one hour
and 56 minutes which is you know
respectable but yeah I didn't want it I
didn't want to do too well so other
people would feel bad about their times
you know sure I kept it respectable 156
yeah
um and then so immediately I so I
crossed the finish line now let me ask
you this when you cross
the mayor the big time marathoners will
sometimes just stop four feet after the
Finish Line I am not a big Runner and if
I run even a couple miles I will not
stop I'll continue walking quickly to so
sort of more slowly bring down my heart
rate yep it's good health-wise it's also
good because you don't want people all
stopping at the Finish Line because then
everyone clusters yeah becomes a mess so
I knew yeah you you jog a little bit
further and then you start walking and I
maybe took four or five steps
um walking after finishing the race
before I could start to tell that
something was wrong yeah I could no
longer really support myself standing I
could feel like my body given out giving
out but I also got the sense that maybe
it was just cramps like my whole body
was failing me but my mind would be
totally fine
then I start to get dizzy I'm hunched
over on this fence that they have that
lines the race and someone within a few
seconds comes over to me like a race
official or an EMT and they're holding
me up they're like asking me questions
um I'm in this panic mode and I'm trying
to like shoe the person away and I gotta
be honest like at that moment I just
felt embarrassed because you know I was
meeting up with friends at the Finish
Line I didn't know if a bunch of people
were looking at me right you know I
wanted to feel like I was victorious in
this whole thing having finished and you
know it was just kind of embarrassing in
a sense and in retrospect it sounds
silly but
those guys like holding me up and like
helping me apparently like a few other
medical workers like started to come
over to help me too to help this guy out
and I apparently at this point started
to black out because they were telling
me later on that I was getting combative
and like actually like pushing people
and like they have pushed a 70 year old
man to the floor
um you didn't kick anyone in the chest
like on the subway did you well I
figured that this story could go down as
potentially on par with that yeah
but yeah and apparently that
seven-year-old man was the boss of
everyone so everyone was giving me props
for doing it later but uh I think he was
okay
um and the last thing I remember is just
being on the ground like I had that
sensation but
I I pretty much lost my vision I was
like totally dizzy and then yeah
blackout for I don't even know how long
maybe 10 15 minutes maybe less um now
let's be clear you BL you might have
blacked out in the sense that you have
no memory of 10 to 15 minutes but you
weren't unconscious that long that would
be very rare
um I I guess so yeah or actually do you
even know whether you don't be
unconscious at all
um I think well I know for like at least
a good portion of it I was
um conscious because I was uh responding
to questions that they were asking me uh
I'm guessing I probably was conscious
for the entire time but just don't
remember what happened but to be up
perfectly Frank with you I just don't
know now did they say with is was it was
this diagnosed as heat stroke yes
eventually it was and did were you like
typical with heat stroke is like if you
take the patient's temperature it's very
high did you have a fever 105. wow okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I uh came to
in an ice bath right
now explain that were you in a bathtub
yeah it was within a med I was in a
medical tent there was maybe eight
people all crowded around me
um and I was in this like yeah like just
like a little bath full of water with
some ice in it uh submerged in the thing
and they're like asking me questions and
I start thinking like oh this is just
this is just the normal treatment that
you get after finishing your race
everybody's in a nice bath and has no
memory of how they were there but it
must be normal yeah that's just like the
process for once you finish the race
they just treat you really well
apparently yeah like your LeBron James
or something after playing a big game
and uh so I'm in the ice bath and then I
start wondering like wait did I have a
medical event and then right everyone's
looking at me like I'm an idiot and
they're like yeah you had a medical
event you're you're in a tent you're in
a you know you're at a half marathon and
you collapse and all this stuff
and I'm just like so confused as to
what's going on still you know I came to
at this point but I was still very very
slow they started asking me questions
again and I began to get them right
funny enough one of the questions that
they asked me was who is the president
of the United States and I literally had
like a flashback to the interviews that
we've done on this show yeah with like
midterm candidates who don't know who
the current president is and they want
to say it's Trump and not Biden and it
literally took me a few seconds even
though I was most of the way there it
took me a few seconds to remember that
Joe Biden was the president
um and they were telling me about how I
was you know really combative with
everyone during the whole process then
they were like okay well we have to take
your temperature
but not just orally we have to do it in
the way that's the most accurate oh no
oh boy what's that and they had to uh
yeah the thermometer went in a place
where I was not uh happy for it to go
but apparently
it is it was medically necessary and so
was there an actual doctor doing this I
don't believe so I think just EMTs are
doing this okay
and then I also at one point thought
that that was customary like they do
this for everyone every race participant
has to have their rectal temperature
taken yeah that's can you imagine oh my
goodness
yep so uh now so so by this so you were
your memory includes how much of what
you just told us it includes someone
holding you up but but then it goes out
when a group of people were holding you
up and then it starts back up when
you're in the ice bath yeah that's
exactly right uh the last thing I
remember was being on the ground and
like I couldn't I don't think I could
see at the time but I you know what your
body feels like when you're lying on the
floor so that was the last memory I had
before waking up some of those elements
are very similar to when I've had my
like vasovagal syncope issues even
though the cause is different where
there's like a heaviness of my head that
starts happening and I'm just like I
can't really like stay up
um sometimes I'm able to lay down and
then also like when it's coming back in
there is this confusion that's hard to
describe where for a second you don't
realize anything's wrong and like when I
fainted on a plane coming back from
Italy
my memory was I was going to take a nap
so at first I thought oh I'm waking up
from the nap why are all these people
around me what's going on and then it
almost like starts to build back up what
happened you know it all sounds very
similar to what I went through to be
honest a very similar process it wasn't
like an immediate collapse or anything
right this slow thing uh but yeah I mean
that was that was most of it then they
put me in an ambulance there are Parts I
don't even remember after like kind of
getting with it
um like uh you know how I got into the
ambulance how I got from the ambulance
of the hospital like there's pieces in
my memory that still aren't there from
that whole experience but they did say
you have to go to the hospital yeah I
didn't really have a choice in the
matter yes they had to give me IVs and
make sure I was hydrated and my knees
were functioning properly and uh one of
the EMTs in the ambulance
um he reminded me like you should
probably contact people because I had
post-race plants right this is the thing
too like the entire time I was training
and running the race you're looking
forward to finishing the race space and
then you can bask in the glory you get
your medal I didn't even get a medal
that day uh later my friend gave me one
because he also ran it and didn't really
care about it
um
but you know you're supposed to
celebrate being done with it you go out
to eat all that stuff and that was all
robbed for me and so when I was in the
ambulance I had to FaceTime my friends
telling them I was not going to be able
to make brunch that day oh my God now at
the hospital what did they do how long
were you there by the time I got to the
hospital they took another temperature
a full thing pretty much they just had
to monitor me you know check my vitals
nothing too crazy had some IVs in me
um what's funny enough too is like a
couple of the nurses were also Runners
which you know is pretty common in the
medical field people wanting to stay
healthy and all this stuff and one of
them mentioned like that she does half
marathons and marathons and I mean I
shouldn't be embarrassed over this
either but like it was it was kind of
funny how it was my first one and like
yeah it put me there uh so that was like
another thing I was laughing about
but uh yeah that I mean that was the
story one of the things I read about
heat stroke is like you really there's
this instinct to give people water but
that you actually shouldn't because
depending on what stage of that delirium
they're in you can you can essentially
get confused about what is in your mouth
and like aspirate try to breathe rather
than swallow and you end up making the
problem even worse do you remember of
anything about like whether who and when
they gave you water if at all I don't
think they gave me water at all I think
they just used the IVs to hydrate maybe
exactly yeah um yeah I didn't have water
until I was in the hospital and I
requested it myself just because I was
parched yeah so I literally had to ask
for it and that was like you know a
couple hours probably after it happened
so it sounds like everything was handled
right right to code oh yeah they were
super professional about the whole thing
despite how I was uh you know pushing
back against them and trying to stop
them from saving my life but you know
I'm super grateful that uh they were
there everyone was prepared and yeah you
know this type of thing happens a lot oh
yeah apparently because you know people
what do everything they can until they
get to that finish line and then their
body gives out on them if I had stopped
running to walk for a little bit around
Mile 10 and my 11 it probably would have
happened right then and there I think
whenever at that point I stopped running
this would have eventually happened and
actually the guy who ran the first
marathon uh died after finishing is that
no no we don't that's how the legend
goes it's like an ancient Greece he ran
to um tell people about the results of
some battle that took place he ran from
the city of marathons to Athens and upon
delivering the message once he got there
he collapsed and died so this this type
of thing can happen and like I wanted I
want to keep racing and you know doing
this type of thing but got to be more
cautious next time well it's been about
a year since a very similar thing
happened to CNN anchor John Berman he
ran the Boston Marathon uh last year I
guess it was and he ended up in the
hospital for three days he remembers to
mile 24 so it's a similar situation you
know marathon it's 26.2 miles half is
13.1 on Mile 24
he vaguely remembers feeling tired he
doesn't remember ending up at a medical
tent in mile 25 so at that point he
already didn't didn't remember what
happened but somehow he had the
instincts to go to the medical tent and
he was taken to Beth Israel he was
diagnosed with heat stroke and they you
know gave him ice packs and fluids he
had a temperature of 104 extremely low
blood pressure extremely fast heart rate
but he also had something called
Rhabdomyolysis where muscle tissue
breaks down and releases harmful
substances into the bloodstream so that
seems like a complication and so he
ended up in the hospital for three days
yeah and are we sure that he voluntarily
went to the medical tent because he
could have collapsed and gotten taken
there uh especially with a mile ticket
the description is he made it to the
medical tent yeah I mean he probably
didn't even know how long he had to go
at that point to be honest but the
reports are he made him made it to the
medical tent it's too bad he didn't make
it to the Finish Line I was able to at
least make it to the Finish Line yeah uh
what a crazy situation it's it's
relatively common uh because you're
expecting to be tired at that time yeah
you're expecting to be feeling that way
you don't think you have much longer to
go and you can push yourself to the Max
and yeah you got to be careful heat
stroke is no joke as they say no
absolutely not absolutely not so well
listen so Pat is fine and he finished
the race and so that's all good do you
think this is the end of your half
marathon career
no I'm coming back stronger than ever
are you ready I will well I think I'm
going to time it better during the year
like uh you know early spring late fall
that way I don't have to worry about an
anomalous 80 plus degree day that's the
other thing too
um you know it's been maybe 60s for the
most part yeah this day in particular it
was it was extra hot not great not great
for race times too I would have had a
faster time if it wasn't so hot I think
that if you're gonna do it again it
would be both do it at a cooler time of
year and also find a way to keep
yourself on a pace that's actually the
pace you want because it often happens
that people will end up running faster
than they actually should because of the
sort of like energy of the race you know
yeah and I actually did pretty well with
the pace thing I fell off at the end
because I couldn't keep moving as fast
as I wanted to uh you know just body
couldn't handle it anymore but still uh
still good and um I was like my most
basic goal for this thing was to finish
the race I have to add another basic
goal I think for the next one which is
to finish and then and not end up in the
medical term I think that that's a very
reasonable and attainable one yeah I
wouldn't be saying I want to run it in
140 or anything yeah worry about that
later yeah that's further down the list
exactly all right everybody that's the
bonus show wow we're all going to
process this and then uh we're here and
we'll be back tomorrow with all of the
normal things